[Música]
un remesón en la política española así
se puede definir el resultado de las
elecciones municipales y autonómicas del
28 de mayo Aunque el partido socialista
obrero español psoe gobierna en
coalición con la alianza izquierdista de
unidas podemos ambos movimientos
Perdieron el psoe se quedó con sólo tres
de las 12 comunidades en disputa y El
victorioso fue el derechista partido
popular o PP que obtuvo más votos y que
revive después de un duro golpe
electoral de 2019 Aunque en seis
comunidades necesitará alianzas con la
extrema derecha de vox para poder tener
las mayorías y gobernar ante el panorama
del presidente de gobierno el socialista
Pedro Sánchez tomó una decisión que
pocos esperaban
he comunicado al jefe del Estado la
decisión de convocar un consejo de
ministros esta misma tarde para disolver
las Cortes y proceder a la convocatoria
de las elecciones generales en uso de la
prerrogativa que la Constitución
atribuye al presidente del gobierno
la convocatoria formal de las elecciones
aparecerá publicada mañana martes en el
boletín oficial del estado de forma que
los comicios se celebrarán el domingo 23
de julio de acuerdo con los plazos que
establece la ley
he tomado esta decisión a la vista de
los resultados de las elecciones
celebradas ayer de esta manera Sánchez
adelantó las elecciones parlamentarias
que se esperaban para diciembre de este
año y las movió a Julio un mes en el que
muchos se van de vacaciones durante el
verano una acción que la derecha critica
Aunque dice estar lista
es un mérito de los españoles a cortar
la legislatura de Sánchez será la
responsabilidad de mi partido terminar
con su etapa como presidente de una
parte de los españoles
trabajemos para que el resultado del 23
de julio de carpetazo a un gobierno al
que le sobran ministros y le falta
dignidad España ha hablado alto ha
hablado claro y ha mostrado su firme
voluntad de derogar El sanchismo digo
que Sánchez quiere que los españoles
elijan entre urnas o vacaciones pero la
elección es otra Hay que escoger entre
Sánchez y España y no tengo ninguna duda
que la mayoría de los españoles elegirá
España
se unirá entonces la izquierda de España
para hacerle frente a la derecha o
logrará el PP regresar a la moncloa
Después de cinco años de ser oposición y
que está en juego dentro de la Unión
Europea para analizar todos estos temas
hoy en el debate nos acompaña desde
Zaragoza España Julio envidia politólogo
y escritor entre 2007 2017 y 2019 fue
director general de relaciones
institucionales del gobierno de Aragón y
ha trabajado con el psoe y en Madrid
está José Ramón riera economista
político empresario y uno de los dos
autores del libro El precio de las
autonomías crítico Además del gobierno
de Pedro Sánchez a ellos bienvenidos y a
ustedes nuestros televidentes les
recuerdo que también hacen parte de este
debate pueden dejar todos los
comentarios y las preguntas en las redes
sociales estamos en Twitter Facebook e
Instagram como arroba
franz24-1 al piso e s pueden comentar
con la etiqueta numeral el debate f24 y
a mí me encuentran en Twitter como
arroba María claguirre no olviden además
que todos los contenidos de nuestro
programa están disponibles en Apple
podcast Spotify deezer y TuneIn
quiero comenzar Entonces por una
pregunta bastante abierta Cómo
interpretar los resultados de los
comicios municipales y autonómicos y
quiero empezar con usted Julio en Vid
Gracias por estar con nosotros
bienvenido muy buenas noches La verdad
es que estos resultados de las
elecciones de este domingo en España han
sido una gran Victoria para el partido
popular y eso está eso sirviente han
ganado muchas autonomías han ganado
muchos gobiernos regionales y demás sin
embargo en España hoy Contamos con ocho
mil ayuntamientos y luego los resultados
han sido mucho más Igualados cuando uno
baja al ámbito municipal el ámbito
municipal el partido popular ha tenido
23.000 concejales y el partido
socialista ha tenido 20.700 entonces
podemos hablar que más allá de todo en
las ciudades más grandes gobierna el
partido Popular en las ciudades más
intermedias y más pequeñas gobierna el
partido socialista
han sido los resultados en un en unas
elecciones municipales autonómicas donde
cada cual votaba solamente a su alcalde
en un ámbito donde debería haber primado
A lo mejor la política local y sin
embargo el debate giro en torno a temas
nacionales veníamos de dos años de la
pandemia de las de una buena política
económica con uno de los paros más bajos
que ha habido en la historia de España y
sin embargo el debate ha girado en torno
a las alianzas del gobierno del gobierno
de la nación en ese caso se ha visto
mucho más favorecido la oposición que el
gobierno o al menos los partidos
conservadores frente a los partidos
progresistas además ha pasado otro
fenómeno que no que no había pasado en
las últimas elecciones que es la
desaparición del tercer partido de la
derecha de ciudadanos en este caso que
ha sido absorbido completamente por el
partido popular y con en distintos
ayuntamientos y en distintas
circunciliaciones el voto de los
partidos conservadores ha supuesto más
diputados al no estar fragmentado son
los partidos conservadores han quedado
dos ha quedado el partido popular y el
partido vox como estará reflejado y sin
embargo en muchos lugares en los
partidos progresistas se presentaban con
cuatro o cinco candidatos
y justo como usted dice el partido
ciudadanos decidió no ir a los comicios
del 23 de Julio José Ramón riera
bienvenido y gracias por estar con
nosotros Cuál es su panorama de los
resultados
muy buenas noches y muchas gracias por
la oportunidad de estar con vosotros
aquí en estos momentos vamos a ver yo
creo que todo el mundo reconoce si la
victoria de la derecha la historia de la
derecha es aplastante siete millones 200
mil votos por parte del partido popular
casi un millón 600 por parte de vox esto
significa muy cerca de los nueve
millones de votos de todo lo que es el
conjunto a la derecha evidentemente si
estoy de acuerdo con Julio en estas
votaciones y no es una decisión de los
votantes fue una decisión del presidente
del gobierno hacer un debate exactamente
nacional no un debate local en el cual
si se votase solo exclusivamente al
candidato de los ayuntamientos o a los
candidatos para las comunidades
autónomas sino que el presidente decidió
establecer básicamente un referéndum
Sánchez y Sánchez no con lo cual Sánchez
se han contado con lo que él ha querido
ver es decir que en estos momentos y por
sus políticas y sobre todo y ahí es
donde tengo que discrepar con Julio sí
por su nefasta gestión económica y pues
realmente tiene el este En estos
momentos el país se ha revelado en
contra del partido socialista solo los
datos para entrar si queremos en un
momento en el tema económico sí España
es el único país el único país de los
seis grandes de la Unión Europea la
Unión Europea Alemania Francia Italia
Países Bajos y Polonia que todavía
todavía está por debajo en pib es el
único que decrece y decrece un 1,3 desde
el inicio de la pandemia desde el 31 de
diciembre del 19 hasta el 31 de
diciembre del 2022 España todavía está
un 1,3 por debajo de acuerdo con los
datos de un estado a precios reales y
además la renta per cápita de los
españoles con la gestión de Sánchez y ha
decrecido un 2,3% mientras la de
Alemania ha decrecido un solo un 0,3 y
somos el sexto país de los seis primeros
de la Unión Europea en mayor de
crecimiento y esto se ha votado Y esto
es una decisión en la cual los españoles
lo sabían y han votado pero no tanto
efectivamente por por sus candidatos
municipales sino por decidir penalizar
en este caso al partido que gobierna a
los dos partidos que claro y como usted
dice estas elecciones municipales y
autonómicas se convirtieron en un
referendo a la gestión del gobierno
socialista Y es ahí donde Pedro Sánchez
responde adelantando los comicios
generales sin embargo esto también lo
hace un poco como para evitar el
desgaste de el gobierno y de los
partidos de izquierda pero no es una
medida arriesgada Usted qué opina Julio
a ver Sánchez tiene un punto de audacia
que no han tenido otros políticos en la
anteriormente y se le ha dado por muerto
en numerosas ocasiones sin embargo lo
que él plantea Es evidente es el que él
quiere un enfrentamiento entre dos
partidos quiere enfrentarse al partido
popular y ofrecer sus políticas y sus
defensas de los derechos de las clases
trabajadoras y salario mínimo la reforma
laboral como como sus banderas y
enfrentarlas a la política del partido
popular junto a la extrema derecha de
vox es lo que quiere es que en ese marco
intentar que sea una dicotomía Entre él
o lo que podría venir en este caso
la fragmentación a su izquierda y que
todavía no esté claro Cuáles van a ser
las candidaturas Y si va a haber una
unión entre sumar unidas podemos y los
nacionalistas de izquierda en una o en
varias candidaturas es lo que le ha
hecho a él acelerar los plazos en
cualquier caso en diciembre tenían que
ser las elecciones no un adelanto muy
extremo y además pasa otra cosa que
España tiene la presidencia rotatoria de
la Unión Europea que es mucho mejor que
vayamos a una presidencia de la Unión
Europea con un presidente ya sea Sánchez
o ya sea hijo que tenga el respaldo de
los ciudadanos rotundos en ese caso en
lo que quiere es confrontar intentar que
las mayorías sean más estables ya sea
hacia un lado o hacia el otro el
fenómeno que vamos a sufrir o vamos a
tener lo que se plantea en cualquier
caso es un mayor bipartidismo con
respecto a la inestabilidad que supuso
el final del gobierno de rajoy y el
comienzo del gobierno de Sánchez donde
las terceras y cuartas fuerzas políticas
tenían muy buen resultado
te quiero preguntar a usted José Ramón
porque Julio habla de audacia de un
movimiento Audaz y un poco Sánchez él
está jugando al todo o al nadar a la
izquierda que como bien lo dice Julio
estaba fragmentado sobre toda la
izquierda del psoe o pues no hacerlo no
lograrlo Y de alguna manera tener un
gobierno de derecha y también usted
mencionó a feijó simplemente para
contexto de nuestros televidentes
Alberto Núñez feijó el presidente del PP
el partido popular Le quiero preguntar a
usted entonces José Ramón cómo
interpreta esto por ahora lo de los
comicios generales si si es una buena
jugada o no por parte de Sánchez y más
adelante vamos a analizarlo de la
presidencia rotatoria en la Unión
Europea
ha sido una sorpresa yo creo que una
sorpresa absolutamente para todos ningún
politólogo ningún analista esperaba esta
decisión de Pedro Sánchez si la miramos
en su contexto tiene sentido el primero
tiene todo el sentido del mundo
anticipar las elecciones y la situación
de Sánchez dentro de su propio partido
es de alta confrontación con la mayoría
de sus balones fundamentalmente por su
decisión de estar en un gobierno no
solamente con unidas podemos que es el
comunismo puro y rancio antiguo sino a
más depender el 100% de un gobierno que
se llama internamente dentro de nuestro
país Un gobierno Frankenstein apoyado
por asesinos de eta como se ha
demostrado que han salido electos en las
listas de bildu y sino por además
apoyado por los independentistas
catalanes su situación interna dentro
del partido después de este resultado es
tremendamente complicada y antes de
enfrentarse ir a una digamos moción de
censura interna ha decidido tomar el
riesgo de convocar elecciones
evidentemente si esto tiene primero para
el país me estoy de acuerdo con Julio en
esto tiene una ventaja es decir el que
salga electo va a poder representar a
España como presidente del Consejo de la
Unión Europea de una manera mucho más
eficaz y ahora el único tema Si
evidentemente se viene dictado por el
tempus de de los días que se tienen que
tomar para las elecciones es la
convocatoria de unas elecciones un 23 de
Julio cuando la mitad del país está de
vacaciones Bueno pues ahora será
cuestión de que los partidos sean
capaces de movilizar a sus votantes para
que acudan a las urnas y del día 23 se
retrase en las vacaciones de los
españoles En definitiva yo creo que para
todos es absolutamente Bueno un anticipo
de las elecciones incluido para el
presidente porque en además y lo
estábamos viendo justo antes de las
elecciones
la desavenencia que había dentro del
gobierno entre los miembros de podemos y
los miembros del partido socialista era
total los enfrentamientos eran públicos
y sostener un partido o sea un gobierno
que está enfrentado directamente
Y de forma interna es mucho mejor
anticipar elecciones y yo creo que en el
fondo todos todos los españoles le
agradecemos la oportunidad de que se
hayan participado y de acuerdo que seis
meses puede ser anticipado las
elecciones Sí y eso como usted está
diciendo aceleró la unión de una
izquierda que estaba más atomizada por
lo menos en un intento y es que Yolanda
que es la vicepresidenta segunda del
gobierno de Pedro Sánchez ya inscribió
el movimiento sumar que espera reunir a
los partidos que están a la izquierda
del psoe sin embargo Todavía están duda
si podemos que es uno de los aliados de
gobierno del psoe se unirá o no a sumar
lo que pasa es que ahora ante el
adelanto de las elecciones generales Ya
solo puede tomar la decisión hasta el 9
de junio es decir un eterno debate que
se había tomado meses Ahora tiene que
tomarlo en cuestión de días Julio
logrará unirse la izquierda sobre todo
dentro de la sombrilla de sumar Y qué
implicaría esto para las elecciones
anticipadas
yo quería contarles a los televidentes
una cosa de cómo funciona el sistema
electoral español el sistema electoral
español se Escoge por provincias no se
vota a Pedro Sánchez o al partido
socialista a directamente al candidato
no es un sistema presidencialista sino
es un sistema parlamentario donde
escogemos 350 diputados en 50 provincias
Esto es lo que hace es que las
provincias más pequeñas menos pobladas
donde se escogen entre tres y cinco
diputados el tercer y cuarto partido
normalmente no tienen representación y
es lo que En España se suele Llamar voto
útil si tú votas a un partido que está
por debajo del
15%, la ley electoral y el reparto de
circunscripciones pequeñas queda muy
perjudicado eso siempre le ha pasado a
los partidos de Centro le pasó a pide y
le pasaba anteriormente
a la izquierda del psoe en estas
elecciones municipales estos días la
izquierda ha visto que ir con cuatro
candidaturas no funciona y es inevitable
que el proceso de durante una semana en
torno días se configura una coalición de
partidos de ocho diez partidos
diferentes con una sola siglas para que
puedan aspirar a votos en las
circunscripciones medianas y pequeñas
probablemente las pequeñas sea imposible
porque hay circunscripciones donde se
escogen tres y generalmente el ganador
saca dos el segundo saca uno y el
tercero no saca ninguno eso es lo que ha
favorecido en los últimos años a la
izquierda cuando unidas podemos era solo
una candidatura y no iba izquierda unida
por un lado más Madrid podemos por otro
y es lo que ha favorecido a la derecha
que con muy poquitos más votos más que
la izquierda en Ahora son las
municipales cuando había dos
candidaturas de derecha frente a cuatro
o cinco candidaturas en las capitales de
provincia a la izquierda el caso más
sangrante ha sido el caso de huesca por
ejemplo donde el voto de cinco partidos
ha estado por debajo del 5% y han sacado
menos han sacado ningún concejal que si
hubieran ido en la misma coalición
probablemente huesca tendría un alcalde
socialista y sin embargo va a tener un
alcalde popular porque las izquierdas
fueron incapaces de unirse en unas
mismas Islas Sí pero sí quiero quiero
interrumpirlo para hacerle precisamente
esa pregunta de usted cree que la
izquierda ante este panorama logrará
unirse para las generales
el fracaso del domingo no tengo ninguna
duda
y usted José Ramón qué opina logrará
unirse la izquierda sobre todo con este
proyecto de sumar
separados vayan en la próxima en la
próxima las próximas elecciones en menos
decir participación conseguirán dentro
del Arco parlamentario por lo tanto La
respuesta es Sí sí se van a unir Sí o sí
El problema es que el trabajo no está
hecho entonces en estos momentos no solo
consiste en decir antes del 9 de junio
no presentamos sino va a haber una
guerra a muerte y terrible entre la
parte de comunista de izquierda unida
la propia digamos eh Yolanda Díaz y la
parte de podemos a ver Quién coloca a
sus candidatos para que salgan dentro de
estos comicios y el gran problema no
solo es ese sino cuando si se presentan
Unidos que sacarán una digamos una
razonable
digamos representación parlamentaria
dentro del parlamento van a ser capaces
de estar Unidos a la hora de las
votaciones Porque en estos momentos
desde luego hay una tremenda desunión
tanto digamos desde el punto de vista de
ideas como de confrontación personal Las
Guerras entre las dos grandes
representantes de unidas podemos yo
nivelarla y Irene Montero con Yolanda
Díaz es que no se puede Ni ver y eso a
la larga no les va a favorecer y la
gente lo sabe lo cual puede hacer que
parte de su voto Y esa es uno de los
motivos por los cuales también Pedro
Sánchez ha anticipado las elecciones es
que vaya a una campaña de Voto útil en
el cual va a pretender llevarse una
parte de los votos del partido comunista
o de la parte izquierda del comunismo
para que traten de de votar al partido
socialista y no perder las elecciones
sin lo cual Bueno pues es perfectamente
legítimo para cualquiera que se presenta
lo cual no quiere decir que le vaya a
salir bien rápidamente Julio quiero
darle a usted la palabra para
contrarrestar si usted está de acuerdo
con esto que dice José de que hay una
guerra a muerte entre los socialistas y
lo y podemos
hombre hay una cosa que está Clara y es
que el gobierno de Sánchez ha sido capaz
de sacar presupuestos todos los años y
ha sido colecciones muy estables las
autonómicas donde los gobiernos de
izquierda cada año sacaran presupuestos
cada año aprobar nuevas leyes y aguantar
unas legislaturas completas Donde ha
habido coaliciones conservadoras no ha
habido presupuestos ha habido adelanto
electoral y ha habido más gasto para los
ciudadanos
prolongando presupuestos como ha sido en
la comunidad de Madrid en Castilla León
o en murcia en cualquier caso sí que Es
evidente que los problemas a la
izquierda del psoe en torno al núcleo
unidas podemos son mucho más personales
que políticos no hay tanta diferencia
entre las programas de las distintas
facciones pero sí que existe un problema
de trato personal entre ellos y eso ha
repercutido en numerosas decisiones
Ahora quiero que analicemos la derecha y
cómo está el panorama en España sobre
todo entre el PP y vox porque si bien
deberán gobernar en seis comunidades
para lograr las mayorías en los consejos
locales y los parlamentos locales a
nivel de todo el país el PPS se ha
alejado un poco de vox de Cara a las
elecciones generales del 23 de julio y
de hecho en la junta directiva Nacional
del partido fijó simplemente dijo que se
espera que todos los esfuerzos estén
concentrados en el PP un poco para
alejarse de Box que es una derecha más
extrema y que puede ahuyentar los votos
de más del centro del PP la pregunta es
está intentando el PP alejar a vox y si
es así Por qué José Ramón
vamos a ver si yo fuese fijo utilizaría
el mismo sistema que estaba utilizando
Alberto Núñez es decir voy a presentarme
tirado las elecciones pretendo ganar las
elecciones con mi partido gobernar de
forma independiente sin tener Necesidad
de tener que pactar decir con mi partido
que estaba derecha y la manera que tengo
de hacerlo es bueno pues primero
consiguiendo que todos los votos que
tenía ciudadanos se los que del partido
popular y que ya prácticamente se los ha
quedado en estas elecciones
autonómicas y municipales y en cualquier
caso es decir intentar gobernar solo por
otro lado la derecha como la derecha vox
es decir porque para mí es decir cada
vez que hablamos de box y le llamamos
extrema derecha y me sorprende que no
llamemos extrema izquierda a todos los
comunistas
bildutarras etcétera etcétera que eso es
la extrema izquierda de este país parece
que hemos colocado la extrema izquierda
como si fuese algo natural y a la
extrema derecha como si fuese algo malo
primero vox yo no conozco si a nadie del
partido que haya cometido ningún delito
de sangre y por lo tanto yo veo que es
un partido de derechas que tiene una
parte ideológica que se se independiza
completamente de la parte ideológica del
partido popular pero que si hay que
combinar las ideas económicas o las
políticas económicas van a estar muy
cercanas en cuanto a cuáles van a ser
sus objetivos es más las formas lo dirán
va a ser en estos momentos con dos
partidos de derecha difíciles decir que
uno solo consiga la mayoría absoluta con
lo cual tendrán de alguna manera que
entenderse sino porque no ha quedado
otro remedio de llegar a pactos y de los
cuales se pretenda lógicamente una
estabilidad de gobierno a la hora de
poder realizar todas sus actividades y
bueno decir yo quiero decir el hecho por
ejemplo ya se ha demostrado
perfectamente en Castilla y león que un
gobierno de coalición ha conseguido
sacar adelante sus presupuestos ha
conseguido reducir gastos en una
comunidad Autónoma y ha conseguido crear
más puestos de trabajo que los que crean
otras comunidades con lo cual ellos ya
han visto las debilidades que tienen
tira a la hora de gobernar juntos y
Bueno yo creo que han sacado una serie
de ideas que en el caso de que les toque
otra vez gobernar en conjunto bueno
pactarán y se llevarán yo creo que
razonablemente razonablemente bien y
veremos a ver si gobernase otra vez
Sánchez vamos a ver un partido o sea un
gobierno Frankenstein porque no van a
conseguir la mayoría absoluta y van a
tener que apoyarse de nuevo en las
etapas de bildu y los independentistas
catalanes Y eso es una decisión
Julio Cuál es su opinión a ver vamos a
ver aquí José Ramón acaba de hacer un
mezclado que es difícil de comprender
para empezar bildu no apoyo la
investidura de Sánchez que ha apoyado
algunas leyes y otras no es que
República en algunas leyes y otras no el
principal socio del partido socialista
o alguna cosa así por otro lado al PP le
da vergüenza
con la ultraderecha de vox Y es que
dentro de la Unión Europea los partidos
hermanos del partido popular Jamás
pactarían con el partido de la extrema
derecha no vemos a macron pactando con
Marín le pen ni a los cristianos
alemanes pactando con alternativa por
Alemania en cualquier caso es inevitable
que formen gobierno porque es la que
pueden hacer en las comunidades
autónomas como en Castilla León ya hay
un acuerdo entre el partido
de los resultados de este domingo
veremos gobiernos de coalición entre el
box tiene una política económica
parecida pero no es la misma política en
materia social en materia de xenofobia
en materia de derechos de las mujeres y
sobre todo en materia de la Unión
Europea son un partido que es contrario
a la Unión Europea que es contrario a
los valores europeos y en ese caso a la
fuerza ahorcan es decir si quieres sacar
las investiduras
de vicepresidente cómo le va a pasar en
el resto de comunidades autónomas ahora
bien lo que no tiene ningún sentido se
llama el gobierno cuando el gobierno del
partido socialista pacta con su
izquierda y que el gobierno del partido
popular con un partido a su derecha no
sea un gobierno es la voluntad de los
ciudadanos en un sistema democrático
parlamentario usted menciona abascal
estamos hablando simplemente para
Claridad de nuestra audiencia
hispanoamericana Santiago abascal el
presidente del partido vox José Ramón
quiero darle ahora la palabra a usted
para darle la oportunidad que le
responda a Julio Y de paso comenzar a
hablar de las posibles implicaciones que
podría tener un gobierno de derecha en
la Unión Europea Julio afirma que
partidos como el PP ibox van en contra
del sentimiento de el bloque de los 27
usted está de acuerdo
afectaría o no la participación de
España en la Unión Europea Un gobierno
de derecha
para nada en absoluto vamos a ver lo
primero sibox tiene que le quiero
recordar a Julio forma parte de lo que
se llama Grupo parlamentario conservador
en la Unión Europea y en ese grupo no
está Marín vale o sea ser la primera es
decir es importante que lo dejemos de
todo el grupo conservador en el
europarlamento tiene esta voz está los
conservadores polacos están la
conservadora
melón y que forma parte y que es la
presidenta
del Consejo de ministros de Italia en la
cual Pedro Sánchez ha ido a visitar sin
ningún tipo de problema ni de rubor con
lo cual primero es totalmente incorrecto
que sea el circo sea
Unión Europea de acuerdo número uno
número dos
del grupo parlamentario popular es decir
dentro de la Unión Europea ha abortado
en varias ocasiones
en temas muy concretos Pero ha votado en
la misma línea que ha votado el grupo
conservador
parlamentario europeo lo cual esto es
muy importante dos decir
con respecto a bildu y con respecto a
los independentistas a los
independentistas aprobaron y votaron a
favor de
la investidura de Sánchez y han
soportado a Pedro Sánchez de forma
permanente en todas sus votaciones bildu
le ha soportado desde desde hace un
montón de tiempo y no olvidemos decir
que han sido casi cuatro años de gestión
y por lo tanto le gustará o no le
gustará a Julio en la realidad es que
además el partido socialista ha tenido
que reaccionar a la lista de los 44
candidatos desde Virgo que estaba que
habían sido condenados por tema de
terrorismo de los cuales nueve tenían
delitos de sangre y de los cuales dos
han sido
entonces me hace mucho Muchas gracias
cuando hablamos de la extrema derecha y
vuelvo a repetir lo hablamos de la
extrema izquierda española porque se nos
olvida como si fuesen algo natural decir
que los etarras y apoyen como han
apoyado y como seguirán apoyando al
gobierno de Pedro Sánchez o los
independentistas catalanes como lo han
apoyado y lo seguirán apoyando en el
caso de que Sánchez gane las elecciones
y pueda gobernar con sumar que bueno
pues eso lo que tiene que decidir los
españoles Sí en la Unión Europea no va a
pasar absolutamente nada porque gobierna
el PP en coalición con vox Sí el PP no
consigue en las elecciones Claro que sí
la mayoría absoluta para gobernar en
solitario con lo cual a ningún efecto si
la Unión Europea va a notar nada nada en
absoluto porque
no afecta para nada La Unión europea si
en las generales del 23 de Julio gana el
psoe o gana el PP Julio Cuál es su
opinión
la posición de Pedro Sánchez a nivel
internacional ha sido de las mejores en
los últimos décadas en España porque es
el primer presidente que hemos tenido
que habla inglés perfectamente y eso se
ha notado en la Unión Europea en las
relaciones internacionales con otros
países con Estados Unidos que tenemos
una relación bastante buena con la
llegada de fondos europeos a pesar de
que desde el partido popular se iba a
Bruselas a intentar que no llegaran y la
relación internacional yo creo que ha
sido bastante positiva ahora bien
en cualquier caso en materia de política
exterior los dos principales partidos de
estado el partido popular el partido
socialista Generalmente cuando van a
Bruselas intentan llegar a acuerdos y
defender lo que es mejor para España en
ese caso Yo creo que la responsabilidad
que siempre han tenido el partido
socialista la mantendrá cuando le toque
estar en la oposición que no sé si será
este año o dentro de muchos
yo les quiero preguntar por la
presidencia del Consejo de la Unión
Europea que España la asumirá a partir
del primero de julio durante un semestre
esto es 22 días antes de las elecciones
generales en las que el gobierno dentro
de España puede cambiar de rumbo José
Ramón tendría algún impacto las
elecciones en la presidencia rotatoria
del Consejo de la Unión Europea
En mi opinión personal decir no va a
tener en ningún efecto en cuanto al si
hay cambio de de presidente del gobierno
primero en las actividades que tenga que
desarrollar España como presidencia del
Consejo europeo y desde luego Sí sí
tiene que asumirlo seguirá con una
clarísima apoyo a todas las medidas que
se aprueben dentro de la comisión
Europea y que sea necesario por parte de
España representada lo mismo que lo va a
hacer Sánchez sin ningún tipo de de de
de problema vamos a ver si la
presidencia del Consejo europeo es una
es un tema que dura exactamente seis
meses en los cuales evidentemente el
presidente del Consejo puede tener una
acción Más directa para que se aprueben
determinados temas es decir cualquiera
de los dos que puedan gobernar Gabriel
Sánchez o bien fijo van a hacer su tarea
porque y ahí ahí coincido con Julio es
decir son hombres de estado e
independientemente de que nos guste o no
nos guste va a defender los intereses de
nuestro país solo una cosa decir con
respecto a la posición de Sánchez a
nivel internacional
Julio piensa que lo ha hecho
magníficamente bien Yo pienso que lo ha
hecho magníficamente mal que todos
recordamos de la persecución de Sánchez
para intentar hablar con baile en la
última hace ya muchos meses y todos
hemos visto como baile no ha querido dar
una rueda de prensa tira la salida de la
reunión en la casa blanca y la ha dejado
en la parte de atrás solo y Sin Banderas
al presidente del gobierno además
tiene pendiente de explicarnos a todos
los españoles porque ha cambiado la
decisión de la estrategia que teníamos
marcada históricamente con Argelia y
después le pido que por temas de tiempo
ya nos estamos quedando cortos
y y no los has explicado todavía el
motivo del cambio de la estrategia con
lo cual eso ha debilitado nuestra
política exterior de forma de forma
sustancial y termino ya Ahora quiero que
muy brevemente nos den sus conclusiones
sobre cómo entender estas elecciones
municipales y autonómicas y que esperar
en las generales comienzo con usted
Julio
Pues nos enfrentamos ahora a unas
elecciones generales donde se van a
plantear dos modelos un modelo
socialdemócrata encarnado por Sánchez
donde se va a intentar primar las
políticas en defensa de los trabajadores
y mejora de los salarios y mejora del
empleo y en mejora de los más
desfavorecidos o un modelo donde se va a
enfrentar a Facebook donde van a bajar
los impuestos para los más ricos donde
no se va a tener en cuenta el estado del
bienestar y donde si te suben el precio
de la vivienda pues tendrás que joderte
Ese es el principal problema que nos
vamos a enfrentar ahora bien No todo es
tan sencillo
podemos salir de un escenario donde sea
difícil hacer una mayoría siempre y
cuando haya que contar con los extremos
Y en este caso en un país tan polarizado
como España Será muy complicado que
ninguno de los dos gobiernos no tenga
que contar con un extremo con el otro
Julio lo voy a interrumpir para darle la
palabra por último a José Ramón muy
brevemente que se nos acaba el tiempo
primero está claro las elecciones como
autonómicas y municipales las hagan a la
derecha Pero además de pasada hoy este
país el lunes se levantó de color azul y
de la derecha las generales sí Bueno
pues están son dos meses después de las
municipales yo creo que va a haber un
resultado muy parecido al que ha pasado
en las municipales y vamos a tener un
gobierno de derechas que te da paliarse
y que tendrá que afrontar el panorama
económico que nos ha dejado el
socialismo ya miraremos entonces los
resultados de las generales a Julio
envidia y José Ramón riera Gracias por
acompañarnos y a ustedes gracias por
elegir Franz 24 Nosotros continuamos con
más información internacional
[Música]